the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so uh very
recap of where we were in the last
lecture we talked about electronic band
structure in crystals right the next
year before we said 1d and we briefly
extended with 3d no exchange and just
show you how 3d look like and then we
start talking about real crystals
bravais lattice and the crystal bounding
how the crystal different type of bounds
band respond on expounding covalent
bonding metallic bonding and then we
talked at the end we say reciprocal
space right the how we represent
periodic 3d functions and using the
Fourier transform and for that how we
need to say the the universe of this in
3d Fourier inverse is in the reciprocal
space so if we have a real lattice real
space lattice with the primitive lattice
vectors a1 a2 a3 we see we can the
corresponding reciprocal lattice vector
is a B 1 B 2 B 3 will be here B 1 is a 2
a 3 and B to you or just to permute the
index so B 2 is a a 3 cross a 1 right so
with that you can construct this is the
primitive lattice the lattice vector you
can construct array of points using the
reciprocal lattice vector G and this is
a say this is the way you construct a
reciprocal space and correspondingly you
have a primitive unit cell in reciprocal
space and and also we can ER Seitz cell
that's a unique way construct a unit
cell primitive unit cell right and we're
gonna tie cell there's also not another
length easily this smallest volume is
the first urban noise Oh
and now if you take a real space less
Swagerty which consists of an integer N
1 n 2 n 3 combination of a 1 a 2 a 3 and
you take the reciprocal lattice vector G
and then you do their dot product and
the USA because of the Carissa takes
this is the volume for the real space so
because the khari sticks of this cross
product you'll find out that GT is just
2 pi times the integer okay
so that's a those are purely the
reciprocal space I was joking is really
mathematic concept right it's the
Fourier transform over of real space and
so I say in turns out it's much easier
like when we electric engineer always
use frequency and physicists like to
represent every set in the reciprocal
space and also at the end of last
lecture I talked about the broad
condition right I give you if you have a
periodic structure you have wave comes
in and I have a crystal for example and
the wave comes to me could be x-ray it
could be electron wave in transmission
electron microscopy use the electron
wave x-ray you have photon waves and you
use a detector so a wave has a wave
vector K incident let's say this is the
final outgoing wave vector right and it
turns out the if you have a periodic
structure here crystal and the condition
where you can detect this your detector
this is your source the condition you
can detect a signal is when ki minus KF
plus minus G equals zero so this is a
day broken
okay and that we give this in at the end
of nice and last lecture and we went to
Google Images I look a lot of
diffraction patterns and for x-ray we do
to Sita measure the diffraction picks
right so for me always say here is where
I struck a lot but I want to actually go
through the proof of the broad condition
or not and because it's a little bit of
mathematical intensive but I still want
to do it and so next I want to give you
a mathematical proof alpha brass a
condition and it's a conceptually is not
that difficult I have a wave comes in so
I can represent the wave in a vector
form right so a plane wave if you recall
we give thee so whenever we this could
be an x-ray photon wave could be
electron wave so the a wave is a wave
vector K I write and the direction the
coordinate of this wave I'm considering
so I want to look at a specific point R
so if I take here right this is my
coordinate system and this is a from
here to here is my R and let's say this
is my sauce right so I write this is my
R I so the vector between this point and
this was is R minus RI right that's the
from sauce to the point in the crystal
so this is the distance the direction
that the wave propagates okay time here
our months RI so this is the wave a
plane wave that traveling towards a
point
R
the crystal right if you see this point
that is the atom there actually come see
the atom we can scatter the x-ray same
if it's the electron wave atom there the
electron interacted with the atom and
the electron gets scattered right so I
will get scatter so I have let's say the
this ignore the scatter signal of course
is going all the rushing but I'm looking
at my put detector is placed here so I
want to look at the scatter wave into
this direction into a direct detector
right and of course say this scatter
depends on the weight of the si the
atomic structure the electrons electrons
of the atom itself but I'm not going to
care so I say this is a scatter and
preview of that scatter way right and I
know it will be proportional to the
density of the atom
meaning the lumber there if I have an
atom there is get scattered if I don't
have an atom it doesn't get scattered
right so in the crystal I have a
location for these atoms and the scatter
wave come back to my detector so let's
say this is our this is from here you
say this is my vector RF so the distance
travel between this signal between the
scattering point that detector is RF MSR
so this is the I K F x RF minus R right
so this is n R is either each R point
but of course when my signal comes in at
how crystal I have many atoms so I have
to the total detector signal is
integration of the each atom see how
much a signal is scattered to my
detector right so
I will integrate I will integrate this
signal this is the incoming this is
scatter right so it's I will integrate
over the volume of the crystal this is a
distress signal at the detector right ah
again I see some puzzle here this is a
plan wave comes in this is a plan wave
scatter to the detector and this is
where there I have atom there and this
is how many atoms that have in the
crystal right and now this is a crystal
so the arrangement of the atoms is
periodic right so here I say n R and in
1d if it's a periodical for your
function you know how to do the Fourier
series is a sine cosine and in 3d the
Fourier expansion is and G this g is my
reciprocal lattice vector and they are
sum of all those points and exponential
minus I R times G okay so this is the
expansion of a periodic function in
reciprocal in the fuller space
reciprocal space okay and you can prove
it if you do R plus T he is my Q article
functioning in real space right because
this atoms is a few article range and if
I do G & G I substitute in the master I
are now is our plot times T times G
you can say T times G T times G is a 2
pi times the integer exponent is your 2
pi I 2 pi is what right so if you to do
your math here this essentially is an R
so that says my Adams is if you article
arrange that's why say let's say this is
the way I expand a 3d periodic function
in this case is the atomic location in
the reciprocal space the Fourier space
okay so our with this now coming back
this is a this is a digression that's to
say my NR I can expanding in G right in
the sum of G I still have to do the
integration over the volume for this our
different arm right different points in
the atom so now I substitute this n in
terms of my expansion G is the son so I
have an integration volume and the sum
over G I can invert I say I can exchange
the order so if you follow my math what
I wrote right legs as I exchanged the
summation after I explained the N in
terms of G and then exchanged the
summation with the integration so what I
have is G and and then say exponential
so all those coefficients are a times s
I just the space it independent and I
will have I K I and R I this is a plus
if I look at my first exponent these are
the irrelevant exponent that they
because it's related to position of
detector so I have i KF x RF
right those I said those are irrelevant
it's just a factors depends on where you
put the detectors where you take your
coordinate right what's relevant is now
as I said I switch to that integration
with the submission right I put an
integration now here and what I really
have because this integration over our
volume right so this term I have ki
times R this term I have KF times R here
I have R times G right all exponential
functions so now I have exponential of
minus I K I if you write all them
together minus KF r here is a plus G
hands our D volume so this is what
matters here right and what do you see
here if you plot this function
exponential function right the eye is a
sine cosine right what happens when you
add them many you see this is a volume a
typical Krister has 10 to 23rd atoms
right one more I'm just giving you the
lumber if you saw many many sine cosine
what do you get right see each one there
is a small difference right the position
is that has a small difference right
incident we vector we say the the
detector we vector go into detector
reciprocal lattice those are constant so
if you sum many sine functions you get 0
right you get a 0 most of the time
except that when this exponent itself is
0 right so the only way so if you put a
detector here what it means
if you put the detector in utterly if
it's not in the right position you don't
measure any signal that's the
diffraction that's why you see this spot
last time when we show the TEM right so
this one is to ensure the condition here
is this has to zero and that's my broad
condition okay so this is a little bit
mathematical lengthy but at the point I
want to say is if you see when we
introduced before the plane wave we see
we can always represent a way by
expanded into plan wave so this is a
vector plan with representation and
scatter wave and using the apurdie city
of the crystal anytime you have periodic
structure you can have a diffraction
effect right and let's say if I have in
this so this is a vector now I can give
you example where I have leaders of
atoms right in any specific direction of
the crystal I look at the sea there's
periodic plans of the atoms right and I
put the x-ray coming here at the angle
theta and this is my incident x-ray we
vector right and now this is a sort of
my 1d plot my pure DCD is a so my wave
vector say the reciprocal in 1d
reciprocal lattice vector is in the pure
dct direction here I have a 2pi over a
this is a 1d right and times the N
okay so now I write a brag condition
because of the one day that we vector
ready our reciprocal lattice vector is a
2pi or a in this direction so I do my
component so what I have is AI is 2 pi
lambda i alumni use it in the photon
wavelength so let's say this is the
incident angle theta I so it's a sine
theta that's the vector component in
this direction right and then my G is in
this direction so and I put my detector
the x-ray is typically this is your
sauce you put a detector symmetrically
on the other side so this will
reflecting the angle equals the incident
angle so that's a 2 theta skin if you
use x-rays people say what's your two
Thetas get rocking curve right in that
case what they do is they Rock your your
root ideal crystal and different
rotation crystal you are rotating
different plan to meet a broad condition
and here in the reflected direction so
you can see my V vector is going back so
in the Z direction I have a leg view
here right
so my is the one I do ki minus KF is
actually I how I get the reflected wave
vector is a sine theta I same as the
incident because I'm looking at the two
angle position the detector
symmetrically right and you know and
then say plus minus G so I essentially
write that as 2 pi a times n ok so here
you can say I put them together
I have sine theta I and a + 2 equals and
nom de so this is a
when you put your detector in typical
x-rays you see incident reflection you
put in say Eco angle and when you
measure peak you know the angle you know
the witness then you go to determine the
lattice spacing in that specific
direction the lattice constant okay so
that that finishes our discussion on the
crystal structure reciprocal lattice and
are now let's move on so we talked about
the electron the lecture we'll want to
talk is the atom vibration the four
lungs okay in crystal so the crystal the
electronic structure in crystal so what
we have next is lattice vibration and
the photons okay so if you recall we in
the few lectures ago we say hydrogen
atom has vibration relative each other
right and when we treat that vibration
we use a sa spread to connect it so in
general the internal chemical potential
is a repulsive attractive we talked with
last lecture right and either the
equilibrium point if you expand your
potential because first order derivative
is zero right so you will have 1/2 K X
square okay and with that you see your
higher order terms but this X is the
displacement from the equilibrium here
right
so the force the nearest order force is
DoD X and that gives me a linear spring
so when we deal with the hydrogen atom a
model a hydrogen same article or model
is a mass attached to spread and in that
case we know again this is a confined
wave right a hydrogen molecule the
vibration is local to the hydrogen
molecule itself and the vibrational
frequency is the K over ere right it's
classical and also the quantum what the
quantum tells us is really the energy
cannot be any number it has to be H nu n
plus 1/2 that's what we talked before
okay and now the question is what about
when I have a chain of atoms connected
by Springs right so I'm looking at a
simple picture as we deal with the
electron I have one dimensional atomic
chain and in the case of electron I look
either they like the potential Coulomb
interaction between the electrons and
they do click the case of the atomic
vibration I'm looking at the force
interaction between the two liberal
atoms right and my model is simplest
because I'm only saying I collected the
atom only to the nourish laborer in
reality if you think about the ionic
potential we wrote before one positive
ion one negative one you can have forces
Coulomb interaction but I also have an
extra negative ion or positive I'll also
have passed a director force interaction
right so I could have a lot of spring
collect from here to here
but I'm not doing that I'm only my
simplest model is only collecting my
nurse labor and now I want to say find
out what they are
vibration or energy of this atomic ship
right and I could go to write in my
quantum mechanical form because if you
record the Schrodinger equation what we
need is a potential constraint right and
that's what we instance your said if you
do a harmonic oscillator in the hydrogen
atom when you write their potential and
we derive without the strong destroyed
equation that's my bug my own say way of
solving Schrodinger equation you have
this vibrational energy quantization
right if you record that
so what we're going to do so if you do
that way you turns out that your
vibrational frequency will be the same
as you solve classically essentially
this is semi in the hydrogen molecule
our case this frequency is a classical
frequency of any oscillator what we have
here is just the energy quantization
right so because of that I'm just going
to solve Newton's second law I'm going
to solve the classically and say get the
frequency and then just introduce you
similar to say if you do quantum
mechanically it's just at each frequency
your energy is quantized okay
and so it's a two different approach you
get the same result and what are we
going to look at now is the atomic
displacement so if I have an atom I hear
right and the UI is the displacement so
is the X I exercise the coordinate right
minus X is zero that's the equilibrium
position there so this is just a
disobeys displacement of
my and I'm going to write the force I
plus 1 and minus 1 so I have the force
equals the equator equilibrium that's
the minimum point so it's really the
relative difference in the displacement
gives me the real stretching or
compression of the spring right so I'm
going to write a F equals MA and I'm
looking at the vibration because 1d is
constraint so I'm not looking like the
other plane vibration auto cheyyam
vibration I'm looking at the Incheon
vibration right so I'm going to write MI
and the mass is the same because it's
the identical atoms so I have mass and
d-u-i so MA so DT square F equals MA
right so this is my act si ma term and
my first term is I'm looking at that
this is the X positive acceleration so
the foot this force is positive in this
direction so I have K spring constant u
I plus 1 minus u I so that's the
relative displacement of the epital I
plus 1 atom and I add ice item - this
force is if with I mass I minus 1 so
that's this direction so I have Madison
ok you I'm su
I must 1 right so that's my RF the force
acting on the atom I MA okay so now I
just need to solve this simple discrete
equation it's not a continuous equation
right because the atom is a discrete
point and if you solve a continuously
equation
you see what's the corresponding
continuous form if I write this 1 into K
yo I plus 1 minus 2 uij plus your I
minus 1 right if you do final admin that
will find a difference analysis so you
know this if you have continuous
equation that's the second order
derivative right this will be the second
if you discretize D yo DX square you
will get a formula like this of course
divided by Delta X square right so if we
look at this if I write continuous DT
squared DX squared that's a wave
equation okay right
and we've equation if it's a say again
the continuum limit my solution as a
function of X will be a wave equation
simple solution Omega t minus K X right
this will be the continuum solution now
I'm just going to use this try to see
whether I can my discrete solution will
still follow this form and in that case
X I so the position of X I this a I
Salim the X location will be I times a
right that's X I and so I'm just
replacing X I plus y is I plus 1 times a
and UI I plus a and going into the
equation so my left hand side is the
time derivative so you I Omega a square
right so what I have here is M the
second order derivative with respect to
time gives me a
and what I have here minus I Omega
square so it's a mus omigod square right
and the exponential minus I Omega t
minus K my location is a little bit
troublesome let me write this as a J
because I don't want to ice okay
J okay and then say I have a K is my
wave vector and the X is I times a
that's the left hand side right and the
right hand side equals K and you can say
my a will pull out and exponential here
I have a common is a really x equals I
here isn't one less so what I have is 1
plus I K times a minus 2 plus
exponential minus I K times a that's
here is 1 less in coordinate and
exponential minus I Omega t naught J
times Omega t minus K I a right I pull
out a common factor among I plus 1 I am
i I'm ass 1 that's my common factor
pulling out and the first one I have I
plus 1 so it's extra item J J sorry
extra J times a and here is a one less
deficient because you I minus 1 so it's
a negative J times a and this is a J
here oh I
all right this is the I know confuse
okay right and so you can say this one
this two-factor cancel a console so I
get a equation for the eigenvalue of the
vibrational frequency Omega okay so this
cancels this cancel and a console what I
have here is M Omega square and leg here
and I have here K and E JKA plus 2 a +
e.message a KA and mass to ej k ms j k
gives me cosine right so 2 cosine ka
plus 2 that's on the left hand side I
have another minus sign here so I put
the 2 in the front so I have Omega
square equals K times n + 2 K because
that's who I can talk put out 1 minus
cosine ka right - cosine K is 1 sine are
two times right 2 times sine 1/2 K a
right so I take the derivative I take
the square root so my Omega n the
vibrational frequency I always take a
positive so Omega is 2 K over N but then
I have to take a positive ka / - so this
is a vibration
frequency of our one dimensional atomic
chain okay and how does it look like
it's a sine function century so when K a
over 2 is half pi is maximum so let's
plot this so what we have here is really
the vibrational frequency this is a KA
so ah this is the frequency of vibration
Omega and the KA so when ka / - of
course PI over 2 that's the maximum
right that means the K equals PI over a
that's maximum right so if I write this
okay here is a PI over a the maximum and
this sign and on the other side negative
side is again say negative PI over a and
it is also sine function is symmetric I
didn't draw it brought joy is symmetric
right
okay and of course you can extend to any
key values so this is what the
mathematics tells us and now let's think
about that what does the physics tell us
so first we want to say what's the value
of K right what's the value what are the
level values of K the we vector right
and for that again I can use two
concepts that I have been talking for
electrons one is a final lens of
whatever vibrational wave between the
lens of the crystal and you do your
fuller transform right you do your food
expansion the other is the phone come
and be a pure a boundary condition and
it will really equivalent so the phone
common periodic boundary conditions say
the first atoms here and they should
equal to the vibration of the ends atom
say this is a na that's the lens of your
crystal right and with that you use the
blocks Europe what you'll have is the
mask I K times n a that's n is the total
number atoms equals one that's what we
used for electron waves in 1d case right
and that means K times the na equals
plasmas 2 pi plus mass four pi orders
right so okay then if you divide it back
here is a plus 2 pi over a and 4 pi over
na continue
so you if you can't is again when ka
time sister is whenever is a really two
pi here
so before I say between for electron
between minus PI to plus PI or a I have
endpoint right that's the case you want
to have n atoms in the chain and that's
the same if you do this your finder
between minus PI over 2 plus PI over a
each point of this K represent one
waveform when I say one form of the way
in the crystal right so call if you go
back to quantum mechanical that's one
quantum mechanical state in the of those
vibration so P term minus PI over 2 plus
PI over a I have n points okay so that's
the K what are they cake and secondly if
you think about in the case of electron
because the symmetry we do not we we
actually only draw between 0 to PI plus
PI or a right the negative side is
symmetric and go beyond this is
repeating so uh in the case of electron
because K is a the other way to think
about K is 2 Pi Lambda that's the
wavelength right so for for long in fact
this waves really doesn't mean and it's
an eel
even from the wave vector perspective
because if you look at ax
I have lattice vibration right and the
wavelength if I have a K equals PI a
what does that means PI lambda equals to
a
I in this point my wavelength is a tool
atomic to atomic distance so that's my
way at this point now if I go to to a PI
over 2 to PI or a what's my wavelength
my wavelength would be this right my way
this way there's no atom moving at this
location so you put a minimum here
minimum here means lesson so physically
in the case of an atom vibration for
lattice web I'm limited between PI over
a 2 plus PI or a negative PI over 2 plus
PI or e and there are if I have atoms
are I have n points between this say
first of all you know in zone so still
the reciprocal lattice okay so this is
the first point
and now I'm going to extend so here I
have a simple into 1d atomic HM
monoatomic every atom is the same right
so I'm going to extend this picture all
for the vibrational normal modes the
frequency and let's think about our
diatomic chain again it's 1d right why I
talk about diatomic if you recall in the
last lecture I see on in a sitcom
example silicon crystal right each
lattice point that I actually put the
two silicon atoms right and sometimes I
put the three atoms right so now I have
a crease up crystal 1d this is again my
pure density a right but I could have
another atom
even at any girl or but it could be
different gallium arsenide there is
another example right those are two
different masks you will see mass in the
city count it once it has a closer here
than here so I could have so nice now
let's say diatomic atoms so this is a
one type and then I have another type
atoms here two different mass okay and
by say my period of the Krister is a and
I have one spring constant another
spring constant it could be two
different spring constant alright so in
one units here I have two atoms okay so
in that case you can go back again
right the F equals MA but you have to
write two set of equation each set is a
move for one specific type of atom and
this two sets of course a couple right
so what do you have I'm not going to
write it down
but the solution what the solution will
look like is again I'm writing my first
point in Rome PI over a this is the K
right and this is a Amiga and we have
steel the bottom solution we draw sine
function but I get an extra branch
because I have two atoms per unit cell
okay so they are what is two branch mean
is the in this branch a more intuitive
picture is the vibration is all in
harmony right so this one this one atom
web Regehr this atom where here this one
is here this one is here that's the
lower frequency branch okay and now the
other are the higher frequency branch
right same wave vector so I don't plot
my different wavelengths in that case so
this atom is vibrating up this so it's
the opposite so this atom now going here
and this atom going here so it's a say Y
is a so that sort of we face the lower
frequency Y is all the atoms two types
are in phase the other one is more
a phase right and other phase is higher
frequency and infinite lower frequency
and this is also uh as we extend that
the full lung each renewal is the
vibration the of vibration conduct
quanta H nu is a photon so higher
frequency one has a higher energy okay
so when they are so that's the different
two different vibration here this is a
COO sticking mode and this is the
optical mode and so later on as we add a
photon so this is a Kousuke branch i'll
cost your photons up your phone lines
okay yes well the so optical is when you
have a light some of the light because
the higher frequency so infrared light
for example could interact the easier
you have to have that when you have the
photon interact with the atom the energy
has to match again right so class sio2
right the glass why you have greenhouse
effect because the vibrational frequency
is about 10 microns and they lie the
immediate in this room is about 10
micron and light hit the window and get
a resident between photon energy and say
vibration there to get absorbed so the
energy doesn't escape
that's your greenhouse effect okay so
now we have a acoustic branch after
branch I'm going to pile more onto it
it's a 1d right so in the model I have
the vibration Direction is the same as
they
wave propagation direction what is that
way
longitudinal right that's the sound wave
you hear sound wave is a longitudinal
way but if I relaxed to say this atom
can also vibrate out of this chain
direction I gather the other motion
transverse motion right do you think
that it's easier to do this way
longitudinal motion or it's transverse
transverse is it so in terms of the mode
so this is the software so a chair if
you say atoms there is the easier to
vary this way or vibrate this way
1d a chair is probably if you think
about a one-dimensional Tomica chair
right it's it likes to fold right that's
a transverse direction right it's a
lower energy so now if I do transverse I
got that I can decompose the transfers
into perpendicular direction right so in
general so if I relaxed to 3d motion I
only do allow say 0 to pi over a and
remember there is symmetrical egative is
the same the ration right so what I have
this is a longitudinal and this is the
transverse right and the other comment
is either the zoom Center the boundary
here right is my maximum so this
gradient here is zero typical vibrate
this is the safe energy or a frequency
dispersion relation at the boundary is
perpendicular okay so here I have a
longitudinal
acoustic longitudinal quotes to the
branch
I have transfers acoustic branch okay
yes huh
well so okay this is the wave
propagation direction the web reaching
is this direction
that's one vibration into this direction
that's the order ah if it's a 1d chain
it doesn't differ but in 3d crystal in
one direction vibrator and the other
perpendicular direction they may not say
the right environment okay let's see
you're right in many cases they actually
degenerate you for the to directly if
you look at to predict direction they're
the same so you actually see one line
but that actually implied their two
branch that's degenerate remember the
degeneracy I'll come back to that
degeneracy again say after we discuss
all those dispersion relations so this
is acoustic so here I have optical three
branches say again
transverse non junior branches okay and
so that's they going from one dc1
monoatomic diatomic to 3d and of course
this is 3d is say 3d in the sense that I
still I consider one with vector
direction now you go to Crystal in
different direction you plot a different
set of curves okay and so here one more
if I have M atoms so here is a diatomic
right so if I have M atoms per basis
so the lowest three so I have a and I
have n points lattice points right so
now you do your accounting they I have
three and acoustic branch so the lowest
of the branch is acoustic acoustic your
mode not branch three and closer your
Mo's right because here if you turn
negative PI over a two plus power a I
have end point I have three branch
that's three in right and then I have
the rest is three M minus 1 times n
optical modes ok so up to your modes the
more atoms you have per unit see a per
lattice point the more after modes you
have okay now this is all continuum
mechanics or not continuum mechanics it
could be but it's a classical mechanics
F equals MA right but could be atoms so
it's a discrete but classical mechanics
now what the quantum of ad is like what
I commented before the energy either
each mode cannot be continuous right and
normally vibration energy is the kinetic
energy plus potential energy you add
that could be a continuous function and
what quantum tells you either each mode
each frequency
each mode and either frequency the
energy of that mode is a one-half say a
shaneoh times say times
of n plus 1/2 okay
and again this 1/2 is 0 say zero point
energy zero point energy is actually a
requirement of the uncertainty principle
because here when we draw I can see the
atom these exact cities here if it's
exactly here its location it is a fixed
heisenberg uncertainty principle will
say its momentum is expanded to infinite
right so because of that this say say
white there is always this 1/2 h no
that's a zero point energy and there's a
in fact at some connection of this to
the force interaction between this one
it's a de fundamental so it's a wonder
wise force is equivalent to the zero
point energy there are some interesting
connections so that's the this is what
the quantum if you do your if you solve
your Schrodinger equation with the
potential harmonica potential and you
get a or the dispersion same as a
classical but you get the energy content
we didn't take that approach right so
this quantity know that basic energy
quanta is a full arm same as the energy
quanta as renewable for the
electromagnetic wave is a full term it's
another electron like an electron right
so for long photons are bosons and the
spin is an integer spin electron is a
half spin and electron obey the Pauli
exclusion principle
so each quantum state can only have
maximum electron but each quantum state
right here this K for a specific a value
represent the wave function a
vibrational wave function at quantum
state each quantum state can have n
could be 0 1 to infinite of phonons okay
so those are ball sounds and it's
fundamentally different and doesn't have
a rest mass electron has a mass right
what's the mass of Photon there's no
rest mass photon it has a momentum it
has an energy right so you lock either
you can create the pressure but doesn't
have a mess it's a collective vibrations
collective modes so I joked that I had
was a colleague and say after he said in
my class I still don't know what is the
photon a photon and that it's a it's a
it's a fictitious particle sometimes
people say it's not a real particle
it's a so this is a photon it has a
energy and it has momentum H K and in 3d
is K or energy sometimes we write as H
bar Omega
write your H nu depends on whether you
use new or Omega okay so that's they are
the are four lands and now you go to
like I said you go the real Krister us a
different different follow a different
direction have a different dispersion so
again I will go to Google and to show
you those complexity in real twisters
but before we do that let me
introduce some approximation yes
my original harmonic oscillator so very
good questioning I remember exam I just
mentioned glass right it turns out that
I also mentioned the hydrogen atom right
and turns out that in physics in physics
when people talk about photon they talk
about the extended modes so hydrogen
atom vibration people mostly do not call
the fula
and once that was a window fall on
conference and I asked say a very famous
guy say say what about the photons in
class right because the class is not a
periodic it's not a Christian you know
nobody knows he said all right but still
have those modes and I say you ask there
is an even more profound si si
question one could ask in this direction
because when you go to a third term
right here a potential is a harmonic
right second term go to a third term
that's the scattering that's the two
photon statu couple and this is in fact
the fundament for fullfil like light
alone very hard to couple to each other
oh right and by following you easily
couple to each other because of this
third term but if that third term is so
strong right and it can come back to a
factor your dispersion and there's a I
do not know good ways to do it but there
are people publishing paper for example
recently there was a paper on the sofa
line in that turn right and because of
the strong unharmed interaction that
change a lot on the phone on dispersion
they if they then the question is if the
photon scattering is so strong it break
the wave right I say this pass a picture
is I have extended wave through the
whole crystal but say if it breaks the
wave it doesn't say if the
numerous of this the frequency is giving
me time for one period of vibration but
if the you went to break this a safeway
with even faster than the one pure then
I don't see how people I do not know how
people are describing those okay let's
see the next is the approximation if you
recall for electrons we see at the
bottom right we use a parabolic we see
either at the bottom in this region the
first-order dispersion the first order
derivative is zero right and so I use
the proper parabola to represent
electrons and for photons for up your
photon and Krista photon you look at it
it's like a sine function right and then
the simplest approximation that people
have made one is an inner function
rather than that sine function and this
is a the other is flat that's a more
property for up your funa and this is
more property for acoustic Fuma and this
personation is the by approximation and
this Einstein it turns out that the
Einstein first created this model for to
model the specific heat of a crystal but
let's say it's not valid so it doesn't
agree with the experiment we go to very
low temperature that's because when you
go very low temperature most photons are
here and so the specific measurement
doesn't agree so the by introduce the
inner dispersion so those are two
different
dispersion and the corresponding
frequency it is the Einstein frequency
this is the Debye frequency and then you
know real crystal the by model very
often we will do the later were talking
specific heat people typically use the
by model and this K right I of course I
only draw one D and the real crystal is
different the rush you have different K
but the by model actually is an
isotropic crystal so approximate not
only linear in one direction just use
one the Russian represent the whole
crystal so that's a with that there are
some relations in terms of what you can
work what's the corresponding the by
lattice constant here you have to count
the total mode to be consistent okay
so ah where we're going from here is in
the next lecture I'll continue come back
to say use this simplest approximation
the by model or instant model to come
the generously right before when we talk
about the say hydrogen atom electrons
right we say degeneracy is 2 n square
that's how you understand periodic table
okay but now if you look at this if I
draw it in one crystallographic at the
ration this is a PI over a and in
another direction there could be another
dispersion right so this represents a
different mode but they could have the
same frequency right so that same
frequency means the same energy and I
can have many mode to have the same
energy and I have to conduct degeneracy
and that counting is very important if
you want to do any calculation it's a
mathematical concept that's the density
of states we
from degeneracy to dense Upstate and
that will do it next lecture so I want
to use the rest of today let's go to do
our exercise say what we have learned
okay so I want to do few things first
I'll continue to look at a 3d fold on
dispersion right mister we talked to
very simple models but when you read any
paper you look either there's a lot of
curves inside right you will see it's
just a plot in different
crystallographic directions and we'll
also then go to look at the relevance
let's look at some papers okay so first
thing I'm going to use my desktop
so let's first I'll look HIDA oh that's
my last homework and have trouble let's
do this Google I have a little bit how
by using this different way of putting
the sidebar google image
and I want to look at a full lung
silicon full-on dispersion right so now
you look at a silicon right this is a
Wednesday QQQ that's 1 1 1 direction and
this is a 0 1 1 1 0 0 so since Sigma is
a cube right 1 1 Direction is diagonal
Direction 1 0 0 is the any of the main
edge direction right 1 1 1 0 0 is the 0
0 1 1 is if you think about a plan let's
see right this is the this is your 1 0 0
direction and this is a plan all 4 are 0
1 1 direction and here is the diagonal
is 1 1 1 direction okay so you can see
here in 1 0 0 direction the two
transverse photons degenerate into 1
right and the longitudinal fula
and here you have up to your full ins
and by C in the 1 0 0 direction you
don't have that degeneracy so you have
to transfers one non shoot you know
right and in the optical ok
and let's go look hi the silicon
electronic
so we combine structure okay here again
so now you have to say this is a gamma
to L that's the gamma to X is is 1 I
think that's the 1 1 1 direction and 1 0
0 direction and this is a word it almost
if you do 0 temperature and this is the
electron uppermost electron the Fermi
level right so this is a balanced span
those are the valence bands here is the
conduction band that's the lowest you
see that's the absolute gap right
between here and here is the minimum
that's it if that's the band gap and
it's an interactive minimum a maximum
not at the same point right so a photon
comes in if you want to lift the
electron from here to here that's the
absorption process it doesn't have
enough momentum between because they're
between here and here is a big K H K is
the momentum a photon woman and very
small so it's harder for a photon to be
absorbed in silicon okay and if you look
at the electron for garden last night
right Guardium arsenide band structure
okay and they may be this one you say
the minimum that's another and this is
not night right column light right
right so let's look at the this is not
all the Russians this is just a drawing
1 1 1 1 0 0 but the minimum and the
maximum of this valence band conduction
band is that the same K vector that's a
direct gap semiconductor see there you
actually have you see there here there
are different bands right these are the
whole valence band holes and different
bands have different mass effective mass
this is a lighter is heavier mass we
talked to say effective mass when you do
see the parabolic approximation right ok
now let's look at the papers I saw the
steel the best way
I was checking where with journals we
don't know much yet so let's still go
back to Applied Physics Letters ok apply
phase letter is a what's the recent
issue courage
photonics optical shop now if you look
at first paper line Queen even
longitudinal transfer opulently inter
hertz quantum cascade lasers pretty time
family okay so what does it mean I
didn't read the paper I'd look at title
I did look at the title right so what
does it mean my guess okay obviously
sometimes I go there and take a look and
say I can guess what the paper might be
talking about and the quantum cascade
laser is a typical laser is they have a
conduction band
you have valence band right and you put
the electrons so you actually put a
current SEMICON dollars you put the
current into here you put a lot of
electron from external injection you put
a lot of holes to here and now you're
like Tron will fall from here to here
and give off a photon that's the
emission process right Accord letter is
stimulated in machine and this is a
typical American doll laser a quantum
cascade laser is you use that that's it
this is a conduction band right and
typically we just look at Gotham as like
but when you make that gotta master and
where it's in right we have quantum well
we talk about the quantum well so this
is the in 3d right now when you want the
ration you make it a very thin so the
energy start to discretize in that
direction so my wave vectors spacing
becomes very large basically okay and so
it doesn't use the electron hole
recombination to generate photon you
actually use the energy level in quantum
well go from electron to electron to
generate photon and the cascade down the
legs quantum well is the same so
they fold humming stimulate you meet
another photon so that's a quantum
cascade laser but say ah water it must
be is a say in the emission process you
have light you have all say the electron
you have fallen so some of the electron
will interact with with the photon with
the lattice vibration and in this
process when we go to let's take a look
so you could dump a lot of energy to
after phone after folder and if they
they can scatter with acoustic fula they
will become see at a different
temperature drive out of your neighbor
from the acoustic phonons so different
modes they could have learning quinium
let's see what does this paper say we
experimented like we need more
longitudinal for long
and the interface transfers like up
Tallulah social with the electron
transport in resident photon terahertz
quantum calculators so how the this is
the energy levels in quantum well see
this is the one quantum we are different
quantum well and the the wave functions
or I say in the each quantum well and
okay this is the let's see after for
long so the it must be this is probably
the power I don't know whether it is
electrical power or but looks like is
the Raman so up to experimental
longitudinal massive structure to be
measured for long I usually they must be
using Raman to measure see this is a
laser concern so what a Raman process a
Raman process is
when you have fallen this pursuit you
have Christo right you have laser comes
in and now they let the light of the
laser you have energy H nu right now the
photon energy is very small the merely I
say the other 10 to 20 milli electron
volts argon laser is about 0.5 microns
so it's about 2.5 electron volts right
so but this light can interact see with
the photon and then shifter they scatter
light the frequency could be shifted so
this is a this is a say plus minus h-bar
Omega of the fona
so with that you can measure the the
fallen equivalent si population by
looking at its temperature or doses so
right and so that's an example of for
photons and I'm sure I think I should
stop but if you look at it they're
actually quite a few papers in the
seashore jointer on the next few paper
also I saw fooling on topics right okay
stop here
you